i kind of see the first four years  almost as like that was our mistake  phase okay yeah talk to us about that i  guess the biggest one was like uh we  hired some good friends of ours and that  just doesn't work it just doesn't work  at all we thought we were being really  clever that  it had to be rob's best mate and my best  mate too but rob would manage my best  mate and i would notice his best mate  and he'd be fine i knew he was fine for  about a year you know really making a  lot of money doing very well everyone  happy and then it just it just like  imploded and it was a you know a serious  time where  the relationships with those guys aren't  the same anymore so i think you know one  key rule is you know don't go into  business with friends i think  [Music]  you